anyone who watches the Ingram angle
knows this the rot on American college
campuses runs really deep from blatant
anti-Semitism to anti-conservative mobs
these formerly and it's an important
Point formerly Elite institutions are
crumbling under the weight of their own
wokeism and with the fall of disgraced
plagiarist and Dei poster child claudian
gay from her role as president of
Harvard the left feels exposed and now
cornered and they're lashing out there
is this sort of open War on black
progress they're just trying to take out
any woman or person of color who leads
Elite universities this is an attack on
diversity that's why clouding gay was
under attack the fact that she's a black
woman only
added to their thirst to Dethrone her I
don't have to say that they're racist
because you can hear and see the
racism even the associated press joining
in the AP claiming the new conservative
weapon against Academia is exposing
plagiarism not making it up exposing it
joining me now Ned Ryan founder and CEO
of American majority and Dr tabia Lee
former Dei director at deanza college
and director of the Coalition for
empowered education uh Ned and Lee thank
you both for being here Ned it is it's
clear that the left has no to take
responsibility for the death of actual
Academia so where does a place like
Harvard go from here how does does this
can this Dei complex unwind itself will
it boy I I it's going to be hard Peter
uh Pete I think they've committed to
this they've been committed to this for
decades I mean I think Harvard stopped
being uh you know an academic of of
higher learning more indoctrination
Center in which they're they're really
trying to conform students to rigid
dogmas instead of actually free thought
and free inquiry uh they're committed to
this obviously this whole situation the
fact of the matter is they might have
removed Claudine gay as president she's
still a member of The Faculty still
making as of today her $900,000
salary as uh former president of Harvard
uh they are are determined it appears to
continue down this path and the shame of
it is is that Dei this this poisonous
alphabet soup Dei CRT BDS that's being
crammed down these young skulls is being
exposed at for the for the hollow for
the false god that it actually is yet
they continue to double down on it
because they've based their entire
approach to the world the entire
approach how they view everything
oppressed versus oppressor the entire
lens by which they judge certain things
is right or wrong is all based on this I
mean this is an entire world view of
belief system Pete that they're not
going to leave behind and they're going
to fight fight tooth and nail uh to
continue to defend it even though it's
been shown to be Hollow and lacking in
complete and total
Merit Lee is that your take I mean you
heard what one MSNBC pundit said an open
War on black progress the firing of
claudean gay is it is it that or is it
in finally exposing the depths of of Dei
and how destructive it's become inside
our
universities you know as uh Ryan just
mentioned um this is we're seeing the
fruits of Labor of this toxic critical
social justice ideology and how
committed the ideologues are to
preserving it and advancing it um what
happen with Claud and gay has nothing to
do with race or gender identity
checkboxes but what you see these uh
mainstream pundits doing now is
attempting to convince all of us that
that's what this is about it's simply
not true this is about educational
leadership and fitness to lead and as we
saw in the Congressional hearings Mill
gay corn Bluff they all demonstrated an
ineptitude to lead during these times
and to address anti-Semitism on their
campuses and they all should have
resigned the day after if they had any
kind of moral courage or you know um
conscience that's what they would have
done um with the cover up that took
place with Harvard Corporation and gay
and trying to tell us you know that what
we were seeing isn't uh plagiarism when
we see whole paragraphs lifted from uh
Scholars work it's just ridiculous and
it shows their deep commitment they're
willing to distort reality uh objective
truth means nothing to these people what
matters is their ideology and preserving
it by any means
necessary n Ned to Lee's point there are
some in the media now claiming this is
not plagiarism no no no this is not
plagiarism here's how they're defending
her lifting these entire passages watch
I have not seen any evidence that uh
Claudine gay was uh guilty of true
plagiarism this is part of of a well
orchestrated
misleading smear of Claud Dean gay and
of Harvard
University Ned this that was Randall
Kennedy he's a Harvard Professor not
true plagiarism just
copying I mean it's Harvard standards
Pete I mean these are Harvard standards
in regards to what plagiarism is or
isn't and according to those standards
she's guilty of 50 at least 50
violations of plagiarism the amazing
part to me in this whole situation is
that some people have lost such complete
perspective they cannot call
anti-Semitism anti-Semitism they cannot
call plagiarism plagiarism they instead
call it racism they've even got to the
point I mean the whole the basis of this
is apparently meritocracy is some form
of racism and white supremacy because
Claudine gay at the at the heart of all
of this is a deeply mediocre person who
was put into that position position not
because of Merit but because she checked
a box and Harvard was exposed on that
and I think that's another embarrassment
for Harvard that they don't want to
fully engage with is that they are
completely embarrassed they checked a
box they bought into this belief system
of Dei and were completely exposed by it
because Claudine gay is clearly not up
to uh what it took to be the president
of Harvard and lacked any moral
Authority or Clarity on being able to
call out anti-Semitism quite frankly
because at at the heart of it really
quick Pete Dei is racism and quite
frankly is anti-Semitic because anytime
you view the ra the world through the
race of lens by its very definition you
are a
racist yeah an anti-racist gets to be
racist because they're racist against
the right person I I think I have that
right Dr Le real quick last word is is
can Dei be ripped out of Institutions
like this in your experience real
quick you you know um that's a tough one
we're seeing how deeply committed
individuals are to this toxic ideology
they're willing to redefine racism
redefine anti-Semitism redefine
plagiarism uh and and almost anything to
fit their toxic worldview um and many of
us are waking up and we're saying enough
is enough um and we need changes in the
leadership not just the leadership uh
but we need more oversight into what's
being taught in classrooms by uh faculty
members because if it's this toxic
ideology uh and that's it with no
Viewpoint diversity we're in trouble as
a as a society and as higher educations
of learning higher education institution
if you can't say I mean if you can't say
what a woman is then how can you
describe what plagiarism is or
anti-Semitism is I mean you just it's
all at that point Ned and Dr Lee thank
you very much for your time great
Insight hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else